O que usar para substituir o combodart
bem o combodart é medicamento Líder né
digamos assim de vendas na parte de
próstata e é o medicamento que é
composto por tansulosina e dutasterida
eu prefiro usar alternativas naturais
como o caso sal pometo otig de oica pigm
africano extrato Semente de abóbora essa
substância desacelera o crescimento da
próstata melhoram os sintomas urinários
e a função sexual tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias
e também inibem a enzima calf redutase
assim como a finasterida dutasterida só
que com muito menos efeitos
colaterais então se você utilizar um
conjunto desse fitoterápicos A grande
maioria dos pacientes vai ter uma
melhora do fluxo urinário e eu coloco
também o óleo de semente de abóbora
porque ele ajuda além de modular a mesma
enzima Cico Alfa redutase ela Ele vai
ajudar na bexiga ele vai relaxar a
bexiga e ajudar a pessoa aumentar a
capacidade de conter urina da bexiga né
então é importante você tá buscando o
médico que trabalha com essas
substâncias naturais porque a grande
maioria dos urologistas não gostam ou
não conhecem esses tratamentos se você
utilizar essa combinação você vai ter
efeitos de redução da frequência
urinária melhora do fluxo você vai
levantar menos vezes à noite para ir no
banheiro e certamente vai ter uma
redução do resíduo pós-miccional